it's been a wild year in the marvel
cinematic universe with tv shows like
one division loki and what if paving the
way for the multiverse to crack reality
wide open in spider-man no way home and
dr strange in the multiverse of madness
although the intention is to introduce
alternate versions of classic heroes and
villains there are tragic stories at the
heart of these grand adventures and the
dr strange sequel is no different the
film sees a scarlet witch struggling to
cope after losing her children in one
division and desperately wanting to find
another universe where she can be with
them in doing so she dabbles in dark
magic while hunting the super-powered
america chavez who has the ability to
punch her way between universes
thankfully the young hero has doctor
strange to protect her and their journey
across the multiverse takes them to some
wildly different universes although most
of their time is spent on earth 838
which is where they meet professor x the
rest of the illuminati and the variant
of christine palmer they first stumble
through several other realities each
with its own unique visual style
including a prehistoric world an
underwater universe and even one where
they're made entirely of paint but the
scene also hides a surprisingly blinking
you'll miss it spider-man easter egg
although strange briefly name-dropped
spider-man when discussing his
experience with the multiverse the film
doesn't really address the events of
spider-man no way home no don't worry
you didn't miss a sneaky cameo from tom
holland toby maguire or andrew garfield
instead there's a surprising easter egg
in a sleek futuristic universe that
shows up midway through that psychedelic
leap through alternate realities it's
not exactly clear where they are within
that version of earth but it looks
highly advanced almost to the point
where it has an industrial feel to it on
the left hand side of the screen a drone
flies past the two multiversal travelers
and it has the exact same design as the
stark industries drones used by peter
parker and mysterio in spider-man far
from home the drones play a key part in
spidey's mcu story because after tony
stark's death he passes peter the keys
to artificial intelligence called edith
which also grants him access to
satellite weapons and an army of drones
and although peter had learned to become
a more responsible hero since spider-man
homecoming and even becomes an avenger
in avengers infinity war tony clearly
wasn't thinking when he decided to give
a teenager that sort of power anyway
these drones ultimately cause chaos and
destruction at the hands of mysterio
even killing mysterio himself as we all
know the villain posthumously leaks
peter's identity to the world while
blaming him for his death so it's a
little surprising that one of the
universes shows a drone flying around a
futuristic world what does it all mean
we will try not to get too excited here
but a spider-man used to rag in a
futuristic setting instantly makes us
think of spider-man 2099 as you may have
guessed his story is set at the end of
the century long after the avengers of
olderville died or disappeared and new
york has become a dystopian nightmare
that wouldn't look out of place in blade
runner built on the ruins of the old
city the bustling metropolis is called
nova york and it is home to an
incredibly powerful sinister
organization called alcomax miguel
o'hara a geneticist working at the
company winds up having his genes
re-written with a spider's dna by
accident and quickly suits up a
spider-man 2099 to fight the injustices
committed by his own employer now the
reference in multiverse of madness
probably means nothing in the grand
scheme of things it's just an inventive
look at another universe that uses
familiar imagery for fans to recognize
but it would be very very cool to see
spider-man 2099 in live action
thankfully the futuristic web slinger is
already heading to the big screen in
2023's spider-man across the
spider-verse and oscar isaac is
reprising the role after voicing him in
the post-credits scene of spider-man
into the spider-verse but this sequence
is another reason why multiverse of
madness is so refreshing it allows
marvel to really get creative with its
visuals and its storytelling rather than
sticking to its often generic looking
action scenes
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the marvel cinematic universe are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]